dans un volumineux rapport remis au
premier ministre la commission
consultative des droits de l'homme
salut la baisse des actes racistes en
france l'an dernier en 96
dans le même temps ce rapport s'alarme
de l'augmentation dangereuse de la
xénophobie
un sondage indique en effet que 40% des
français s'avouent plus tôt ou un peu
raciste six français sur dix estiment
qu'il ya trop d'arabes en france et 20%
trop de juifs
comment les expatriés de plus en plus de
moins de plus en plus longue date
vive t-il ce phénomène very fournioux et
josé boulesteix sont enquêtés dans l'une
des rues les plus cosmopolites de la
capitale des voix des accents millet au
parfum du monde entier la rue cadet
s'anime avec ses différents c'est quoi
le racisme pour vous
la bouilloire les personnes qui sont
racistes
les personnes qui
qu'ils se rendent de couleurs d'istres
assiste tout en ayant des amis émigrés
groupe l'excité de la vie entre
communautés même s'ils ont comme malika
la nationalité française
souvent les origines se voit une petite
mamie l'autre ça voulait se faire livrer
chez elle mais avouez que ça absolument
pas que ce soit un arabe ou un noir se
laver les bersonnais arabes ou noirs
explique ce soit le patron un blanc des
trucs complot battrons pour que marine
et vont mener pieds blancs d'origine
portugaise s'était fait plus que des
mots le racisme c'est aussi une
sensation jamais de propos surtout un
regard ou un sentiment de racisme
jamais de propos jusqu'à présent est ce
que c'est parce que vous avez l'uniforme
de la poste c'est peut-être possible
mais c'est souvent le statut social qui
définit l'intégration sailpoint c'est
c'est à dire c'est le premier set
c'est à dire que si on met de l'argent
il ya problème ceux qui sont là depuis
des années on m'a ils sont français
limite à françois gilbert si vous voulez
on les a pris le garde
on connaît les enfants qui sont nés en
france on les garde à ils sont là ils
sans pouvoir rien su marché des cds et
ranger du bon côté mais qu'on arras les
frontières maintenant héritage d origine
ou page d'histoire sur le rejet de
l'autre différent déjà vécu des
phénomènes de racisme
39' rien mais en tranches offertes alors
assez méchant que ça soit exclu de tous
les peuples mais une question
d'éducation
ça n'en prend pas aux jeunes
de tolérer mutuellement
chamas je trouve un joli bouquet de
fleurs à lâcher ses bocaux prigioni
aucun sérieux leur honneur que d'avoir
des couleurs uniques tant voir la même
couleur
on en a marre quand il ya des noirs des
jaunes des blancs tous en jeu trop c'est
formidable c'était un voyage avec
plusieurs escales sur 50 m de la rue
cadet